hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm gonna read this my name is
Constance no it's not it's markiplier
I'm writing this note hoping someone
will find this if I'm gone my brother
died a month ago his death was
unexplainable and devastating before the
night he died he was muttering something
about his pokeballs and went up to the
hills in his van ah this isn't supposed
to be funny I am going out there to
figure things out I might find some
clues to what actually happened to him I
gotta find his pokeballs up in his van
okay anyway welcome to let's play pokey
slender to the bloody red Edition
there's a bloody red Edition and then a
something other green Edition I think
not exactly sure all right I don't
really care let's go into here tap to
check your map f5 to save your game cool
I can save nice bike um was that oh
that's my reticle it looks like two eyes
alright then let's save right so far so
good
so we need to find six pokeballs and six
notes by the looks of it and we are
going oh so slow I think this is the
familiar speed of the previous game if
I'm not mistaken but it's been a while I
might have been going even slower before
still that sprint oh the sprint isn't
nearly as stupid man the sprint was
stupid before but this is much better
okay so I'm looking for notes and
pokeballs in search of the mystery of my
brother's disappearance my brother died
trying to stop the Pokemon from nibbling
off his nipples but he failed in his
quest to rescue his Pokemon but or name
wasn't he mentally deranged that's what
I thought was going on in the previous
story so I'm assuming that now oh this
is a girl I see the painted fingernails
on that hand there
red so I'm assuming this is a girl or a
crossdresser I'm not sure hey okay
anyway I hear some noises out in the
woods there but they sound like a cow
more than anything so far so nothing so
gonna try to find something here there's
got to be some landmarks besides just
these park benches here and nothing on
the bench is easy alright let's go and I
must be running in high heels judging by
those clacks so I'm assuming that this
is a girl maybe don't know yeah it's
pretty quiet I mean there's absolutely
nothing going on let me check the map oh
my god
this place is gigantic I must be calming
up the left side there holy shrine holy
shrine okay so let me go in because I
actually I'm probably almost at the top
end by now they said there was an old
truck up that way so let's clack our way
over there I'll show him a better
Pokemon master than my brother da my
brother can't do anything right I just
hop so don't judge me I just have a very
deep voice for a woman I'm a proud
independent woman who don't need no man
her Dona hmm
gimme sorry I just let my inner feminism
gush out of me every once in a while
anything on that park bench nope okay so
I wish there was something on this map
that said oh I can move it oh hello woo
okay alright so there's nothing really
sing where I am but I've got to be
getting towards something otherwise this
place is just friggin gigantic I mean
that's why there's a save mechanic this
place is friggin huge my battery is
actually draining but not all that fast
so that is definitely a girl okay we
finally decide that his girl hey wait a
minute is this a gap in the wall that's
supposed to be here or not let's check
it out nope it's not supposed to be
there I found a bug mister GameMaker man
or not a bug but you know some mist it
doesn't affect gameplay therefore it's
not a bug it's just uh a map error
sullivan found anything in uh okay
there's nothing going on absolutely
nothing nastasi soom that there's
nothing going on just because i haven't
found anything yet ergo I shouldn't be
triggering any pokey slender's to pop
out of the woods but I mean come on I
either want the complete wrong way in
the beginning and I'm now going into
nothingness because I've been running in
the same direction for way too long and
I go oh so damn slow or this map is so
gigantic that I can't possibly get to
the end of it and there's actually an
infinite way that I could go and I've
just been wandering towards and heard
and farted till I can't ever get I don't
even know where I started I don't even
think I started the main gate per se Oh
a different sound
I found the end of the path I found the
end of the path yes that means there's
an abandoned aha yes let's find a
Pokeball oh don't tell me there's like
nothing on this I would be so so
aggravating oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no there's nothing here there's nothing
here there's nothing nothing there's
nothing I climb on top of you you bath
wheat what's that AHA there was
something no though it'd have been easy
to miss so I found one note okay look at
it what was it there was a journal
wasn't there a journal okay whatever I
found the old truck that's all that
matters let's follow the path a million
freakin miles to the lighthouse my god
this place is gigantic this might be one
an example of some
being a bit too big but I mean hmm ah if
I had to compare it to anything I'm
going the wrong way where am I
where's the truck go where the truck go
can me where the truck go it was there
where's the road oh there's a truck god
I can't see anything just pass the front
of my face here okay there's the path
okay if I got to follow this why are
there trees growing in the path there's
dogs am I got any shots
I mean slender hunt was probably the
biggest map in comparison and this is
weird because I'm just getting off a
game where the map was too small
this map is too big because there's a
lot of nothing going on right now
I haven't even found a Pokeball yet I
found a note that's probably 12
locations or something in 12 locations
meaning there's an odor and a Pokeball
at each location but this this is taking
forever to get to them it would be
better if I didn't go so slowly I mean
really there's different speeds between
besides dead sprint and then walking
there are I swear okay so I came to the
first intersection so I just got to keep
going straight and I'll hit the
lighthouse eventually oh my goodness
this is Jarrod as I see it in the in the
silhouetted in the distance there this
is tedious this is the definition of
tedious because I'm already like I'm
like seven minutes into this game and
I've only managed to find one thing I
mean if you think about it the Slendy
Tubby's map is a good example that thing
was huge but you ran really fast so that
helped you get through the map this one
is just gigantic you could deal with a
lot a smaller map like close this way in
and it would be so much better for the
players user experience you got to think
about the player I mean it's cool to
have a big map at all but at the same
time if it's just a burden it's not good
game design but then again what do I
know I don't make games aha I found a
polka bow
oh well okay I don't see you this is a
game of peekaboo I'm good at peekaboo I
beat the crap out of all the little kids
to try to play me in peek-a-boo and even
know looks like a tree on a hill over
there is that some special thing or is
that just another tree it's just a tall
tree it's nothing big it's nothing
important right there's no there's a
tent out here somewhere and I'm gonna
find it but at least now I have finally
nine minutes into the game have started
the slender surprise
slender surprise sounds like a really
really bad crackerjack prize you open
the box in haha it's Thunder got ya
alright let's see I wonder if it's gonna
be the same dark Pokemon that are gonna
try to get me I still don't know a lot
about Pokemon but I mean I used to play
to play the red version one way way way
back on my gameboy
oh those those booming sounds sounds
more like explosion than the typical
what I've always imagined it when I hear
that I think of like if you remember in
Mass Effect those giant what they call
something hammers whatever those worms
were anyway those things like just
mashing into the ground I always think
like it's summoning slender by this just
big noise like omens like slender coming
for dinner some stupid idiot wandered
into your woods again okay I'm not gonna
find anything falling on the path
because I don't exactly know excuse me
where I am I was supposed to find a
temple here but I do not see even the
outline of one ergo sorry I got
something stuck in my throat but it's
adding a bit of raspy 'no stew my voice
there is a certain level of interest I'm
not gonna stop this until I actually
find something okay hang on a minute
have I found something here is this the
tent seems to be something glowing in
the distance yup that's a tent that is
indeed a 10 what is in this tent
from that off oh that's not creepy uh hi
little girl
you actual little girl are you just a
doll you look like you're an actual
little girl so what's the deal what's um
what you watching there a little girly I
don't know that's weird
okay I didn't find anything but there's
got to be either a note or a pokeball
somewhere here so where is it where is
it
hello anything please little girl help
me out here little girl have you seen a
note or like a pokeball or or anything
you're kind of sunk into the ground
they're not really helping me you're
gonna being rude I'm a guest in your
tent low girl come on little girl all
right fine you know what I don't see a
Pokeball but then again in this foliage
it would be very hard to see okay
whatever whatever all right so that
means the temple must be straight across
the way like straight across this way at
least that's my guess
oh no wait cuz the patio it must be diet
must be out there the one on the sides
the patios go up and down
I believe I came from that direction so
we can see the tower yeah the towers
over there ergo if I go this way I
should reach the temple in no time the
temple of Pokemon I don't know
so far I've just been bored with this
game like the atmosphere isn't actually
scary especially in the beginning there
was nothing to like induce a sense of
dread in me there was no music it was
complete silence in the beginning and it
was just kind of really tedious and it
still is it's really tedious for quite
some time where nothing is happening and
I guess the Creator understood that in
that he created a safe system however
this is not an improvement over the last
one one of my criticisms and last one is
that the character moved so slowly and
always got caught on stuff that is the
wall where's the temple
damnit alright looks like I am [ __ ] out
luck wait no I have to cross it but
that's the wall there there's no temple
here dammit
where's the temple there's no temple
here oh my god this is unbelievably
tedious or I mean in the beginning I
messed up by going up the left end and I
should have realized that before I
should have I really should have so I
don't know what to say I don't know what
to say I'm a little whoa hi hey buddy
are you gonna kill me oh yeah now that's
more like it
hey you're back down [ __ ] you back up
what are you some sort of al get out of
here get it out of here get out of here
get out of here Oh get out of here no
Donna think so I'm gonna run this way as
fast as I can in my heels and you go f
off now is what I'm talking about
it's about time I monster decided to
show up I mean I'm thinking I might have
been just a little bit too critical if I
had gone the correct way earlier on I
would have found a Pokeball early but my
other criticism in that this isn't scary
still stands I'm not all that scared in
fact I'm not scared at all what is this
the holy shrine is that what this is how
do I get rid of this bugger because I
can't exactly run and
Tiz Shah man I need to get my pokeballs
Jesus how do I get rid of him how do I
get rid of him how do I get rid of him I
don't know hey who's that
that's a pokeball gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
I can grab that pokeball from a long way
cuz I already got it hahaha was that
okay that was weird
don't know what that was but it was
weird did I lose what's his face I don't
even know who that was but I lost him I
guess so what am I gonna do about this
I'm actually pretty much all out of time
for this one I'll pick this up again
later but um I really I really don't
know I think of it i haven't gettin in I
haven't gotten into it enough so I mean
I don't want to be too harsh I I try not
to be overly harsh whenever I play these
games because when I when I do try to
review them I try to give them the
benefit of the doubt I mean obviously a
lot of work went into this game and I
appreciate that and I haven't discovered
all the game mechanics so I can't make
any judgments this early on so take
everything I say with a grain of salt
just cuz I'm not scared now doesn't mean
I won't be scared later give it a try
for yourself link is in the description
below thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for my videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye
and
okay
yeah
do that
oh good
Oh
yeah